I feel it's my duty to bring these calls
between President Obama and president
elect Trump directly to you the American
people here's the latest
well the rack if I die it takes over his
presence the Vice President Joe Biden is
your vice president Mike Pence I tried
to think of a nickname for my cabin
what's the word for a group of
billionaires I don't think there is one
is it a herd of billionaires of pride
Donald I really have a lot to do how
about it Klan is great thanks man
the liberal media is saying I lost the
popular vote well that's true you lost
by 3 million votes yeah okay but if you
don't got the people of color the
college-educated women or California it
was a real landslide but you do have to
count those people back for log get
anyone to perform yet well you don't
know what huh I was hoping maybe you
could put in a word would be on Singh
she's not gonna do it no I was thinking
about you you rat right don't all these
people
what are those secret sure I've actually
is by working for the Russian government
is this your idea of a joke haha gotcha
I don't really think you didn't get me
because I never believed you then I did
get you because I really have a spy wait
wait wait 30 days I'm a spy half the day
in the decadent allotted I don't know
promote phenomics by going out of sight
[Applause]
[Applause]
you